bonne nuit dit une seconde qui envoie
des textos qui à mon amie camille commis
commis c'est un nom de fille ou un ou
deux garçons ça ça change quoi ça change
rien du tout sauf si c'est un garçon
mais c'est grave acte un garçon oui quoi
taper cheveux sur la tête
oui des fois je la regardais j'imagine
que je vois sortir un petit poussin ne
garantit jamais reçu goût agents lucie
wild de lagence vigilance de lynx
vous allez devoir ma copine non désolé
je
devriez pas annoncé à l'as vence le
genre d'armes que vous allez utiliser
tenez je vous montre où j'allais vivre
ça
parlant
autant
nous sommes lagence vigilance de lynx
notre vocation est de lutter contre le
crime à l'échelle planétaire
un nouveau méchant a fait surface
vous savez comment les méchants résonne
c'est pour cela que vous êtes 6 je suis
le directeur de l' agence sillage de la
mole fait il
c'est vrai qu'il va sauver le monde sait
comment ma vie
si kobe